I thought about opening with me singing
you know hooked on a feeling or maybe
the chain by Fleetwood Mac Ridge has
been on a lot of the marketing but you
don't want to hear me sing
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 so I have
seen it I'm going to talk about it I'm
going to try and avoid spoilers I am
going to want to talk about them
eventually but I'll it throw up a
spoiler warning before I get there
hopefully hopefully I don't get too
wrapped up that I drop spoilers before I
may do anyways short version getting
right to the point
it's good it's very good it's a lot of
fun which is exactly what I want out of
guardians of the galaxy I'm kind of in
my head going back and forth whether or
not I think it's better than well
knowing whether it's as good as the
first one I don't think it's better I
think the strengths of each one are very
slightly I think on balance it might be
as good trying to be objective about it
there wasn't sort of the knock has
against it is it's not as new so it's
not doesn't feel quite as fresh there
wasn't really way around that though
it's it's a sequel unless it takes a
totally different direction sequels
generally you know lack that newness and
um this franchise has already different
enough from you know Marvel movies and
superhero flicks blockbuster movies in
general it is bizarre enough and weird
enough it doesn't need to be diverging
from itself they can just be you know
the weird franchise that it is and it
lives up to that so like I said
comparing to the first one I think the
story is probably not as strong I think
the the first one had a had a stronger
story through line I think this one has
higher emotional levels for some of the
characters and is funnier so sort of
again that's why I'm kind of thinking on
balance are probably uneven footing
although the strengths of one are
different from the strengths of the
other but you know these characters they
argue their back they're fun they're
funny and yet the humor is kind of amped
up
but not just in a cheap you know insert
more jokes way like in a way that I'm
not sure too many directors writer
directors aside from James Gunn could
have pulled it off because this movie
will whip back and forth from you know
attention attempt action scene to a
pretty heavy emotional moment to a
raucous joke within the same scene and
you don't get total whiplash you you are
able to roll that part of it I think is
the sequel benefit now that we have a
great grasp on these characters it can
do those sorts of shifts maybe a little
bit more rapid pace than then used to be
done even in the previous one all the
returning characters are great and
they're all good for pretty much the
same reasons Drax seems to have loosened
up a little bit so he's a he's not you
know buried under you know the loss of
his family although the film hasn't
forgotten that either he gets some nice
moments in relation to that Groot is a
little bit different because baby Roux
kind of you know they play off his
immaturity and so he is functioning a
little bit different other than that the
characters come back and do what we know
that they're good at and they remain
good at all those things and that's true
of even the the more supporting
characters that crossover like nebula
yondu and some of these characters I'm
going to talk more about once I get into
spoilers because some of them have
things that really specifically that I
liked a lot but I don't want to ruin
things for for people who want to go and
blind in terms of new characters we've
got mantas who is fun and funny although
in some ways she feels um a little bit
not redundant but she feels a little bit
similar to Drax you know in terms of not
quite connecting properly with the other
characters and it's for different
reasons and it's in a different way but
that that is it feels like a little bit
of a repeat of that kind of general
dynamic but then we've also got Caruso
appearing as Peter quill star-lords
father and I feel okay saying that
because that much has been shown in
trailers and Kurt Russell is Kurt
Russell's Kurt Russell I mean that's
that's basically what he was hired to do
man and be cool and chill and kind of
groovy and he's cool and chill and kind
of groovy so I'm you know he's doing
exactly what needs to be done pretty
well
I feel like this this one has really
embraced the craziness of the guy that
should come out of doing anything that
is linked to Marvel cosmic canon it
should be nuts and this is nuts more
nuts than I think the first one was I
think the craziest thing to probably
went on the first one aside from you
know a raccoon and a tree was like the
the civilization inside the head haha vo
some giant lost ancient being this
something like that would be really
mundane in this this particular movie so
it's really leaning in and embracing the
craziness that this property in this
franchise brings and I found it just to
be a whole lot of fun which is what I
thought about the first one it was a
whole lot of fun and there are some
surprisingly touching moments there are
tons of funny moments the action is good
and inventive and it was good I enjoyed
it I'm now going to talk about some
spoiler stuff so some things in
particular that I really like so we knew
that Kurt Russell was Peter Quill's
father and anyone who is really paying
attention to the information that was
coming out also knew that Kurt Russell
was playing ego the Living Planet the
way that works is he's playing sort of
an extension and avatar of ego we do
actually see the planet and yes yes you
do get to see a giant face on the planet
that made me so happy but anyway I had
was slightly nervous about this not just
because it's ego but because sort of
since that first one is like oh you know
the implication that his father was an
alien was something extraterrestrial
that was a thread I wasn't particularly
excited to see played out because it
leans too close to a destiny narrative
in my mind it makes him you know he's
destined for
greater things and you know because it's
in his blood and it's how he was born
and I you know that's not the worst
thing in the world but it's so played
out at this point I just I want more
characters who just they just happen to
be the guy who's there
they weren't destined for this so I
wasn't too excited to see that played
out but it plays pretty well and a big
part of Wyatt place pretty well is that
by the time the movie ends it makes it
very clear that what makes him special
is his human half not his celestial half
and that is made really really clear
really explicit and also because in this
we sort of get you know things like well
because he is half celestial because
that's you know ego is a celestial
because he has hassle su if he can do
these amazing things and they removed
that by the end so that I'm glad for cuz
I'm what I want him to be the human in
the group I don't want to I don't want
him to suddenly have superpowers he
doesn't need them um so I'm glad that
that got a dress removed and it didn't
diminish the character in any way
because it goes
look here's this whole thing about
himself he didn't know about and that's
fine because it's all what makes him
special
anyways I like that little mini art that
he goes through that said anyone who is
familiar with sort of the lot of the
tropes of these kinds of storytelling um
you know you know a character meeting
somebody is like oh let me just show you
how everything is well what's the thing
well that person's manipulating them
they've got their own agenda and that's
exactly what's going on and there's
there is that lull in the middle a
little bit and part of it is related to
just it's not hard to figure out that
ego is going to end up being the big
villain by the end of it now watching it
play out it plays out pretty well
but I the I would say that I figure that
out early except that I'm not sure the
film actually tries very hard to hide it
I think I think James Gunn knew
he wasn't breaking in but to do a new
ground with that particular story twist
but yet still left the structure in
place of somebody who was trying to play
like a twist so I don't know I'm not
entirely sure what to think about that
some other emotional things um yondu
some really good neo you get some good
surrogate father stuff there Michael
worker gets a lot of great moments and
some really good bonding with with
rocket
I got surprising potent just background
and understanding of nebula like I liked
nebula the first time and that was like
just because of Karen Gillan's presence
I'd I mean I liked her from Doctor Who
but she brought a great menace and anger
to that character and I just I liked her
as a presence and this one to get a
sense of why she is like this and to get
some specifics of her backstory it it
hits it is kind of hard and I wasn't
expecting that from her and it was a
nice surprise
I enjoyed that I think don't know I
could talk more spoilers stuff those
were the main to spoil things I wanted
to mention that I really liked that I
thought it worked really well so
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks kibble listen to the
council of geeks podcast or the punch
like a girl podcast both available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]